[Music]
welcome my dudes my doggies and my Kazee
boys to the gazebo only zone
I'm your host ethan klein i am sick as a
dog this is my beautiful pregnant wife
who I love and adore she's the angel of
my life in the light of my life she's
everything that I've ever hoped to find
a partner and so much more
Lila climb I am so sick I'm delirious
I'm out of it you know you're still
embarrassed by my introduction I see
yeah it's true it's all true and so much
more thank you I am so sick I am
completely out of it yeah I've been
pumped with all the quills the bacon
wheels the knight coils the Twilight
quills what do you get when you combine
nyquil and dayquil I'm in the Twilight
well right now and start a Wiccan quill
oh yeah after today I'm gonna be weekend
coiled out oh and thank you to our
sponsors audible me undies LinkedIn I
almost forgot about those great dudes
I'm so out of it so this is gonna be a
roller coaster ride guys thank you for
joining us on this beautiful blessed
Friday Oh
Friday don't we all love it so much yes
I'm happy to share this special day with
you all
we had Tom Segura and Christina P two of
my favorite people on the planet were
scheduled beer on Wednesday I was sick
unfortunately we're gonna get him back
on here soon I love those guys went to
Disney yesterday with my family which
made my illness worse so but you know
what that's enough about what's going on
in my life let's get to the science of
why we're all here today last week and
it's been part of the show mythology I
would say is we have these Twitter polls
which really illuminate I would say some
of the darker parts of our society not
dark in the sense of being tat being
unethical or nothing to be feared but
I'm on dark in the ocean shadows in the
shadows and that it hasn't yet been
uncovered or looked at
yeah we are we are great searchers
weirdoes great discovers we are now all
the pranksters do like social
experiments this is real [ __ ]
she's the parent dude I want to be
surprised to see some of these Twitter
polls being quoted in such reputable
articles as Wikipedia so we have one
last week about do you smell on your
hand and you fart on your hand and smell
it I'm so out of it
do you fart on your hand and smell it so
first we did do you like the smell of
your own farts
and most overwhelming obviously yes and
there was some nice don't understand it
like I got it kind of upset because I
feel like you were kidding but you're
saying that you're serious but like
you're kidding well the poll speaks for
itself
yeah so first of all there was some
disbelief that people liked the smell of
their own farts but then we took it a
step further we said do you fart on your
hand and smell it and most of the people
in here except for Zach who's only
honest being here was like what is wrong
with you they say they say Ethan you are
a you shouldn't exist they say to me so
let's go to this poll because this was a
prolific vote I would say this was a
paramount benchmark vote we took place
here
have you ever smart farted on your hand
and smelled it a hundred and twenty four
thousand votes that is a huge number and
let me say 51% yes mm-hmm
and after this poll I bet you it's gonna
go even higher we even saw a couple when
we were at Disneyland and the guy had to
tell me that he does it too yeah an
ex-girlfriend I said can I smell your
head
Eleni stew I sniffed his head he had a
turkey leg in it and it was a fart and a
turkey leg it was a great time we had
there Disneyland so there you have it
guys this is science this is real
science we're doing here amazing but
then so I got an email from a fan
a podcast at age six reproduction calm
and she blew my ass out with a new one
she wanted to broach with us mm-hmm
let me read this email from autumn
autumn gee hello Ethan and Ella lately
on the show you guys been talking about
your girls habits in ela almost every
time has said she does not share these
strange routines so as a heel kleiner I
admit when I'm on my cycle I will often
smell my blood nope
sometimes I find it satisfying and
sometimes I find it gross lately my
blood has smelled similar to red wine
and I've never smelled my blood when
it's in it oh she says and I never smell
my blood when it's in a tampon well how
does she smell it this so I hate the
smell and that is why I usually prefer
to wear a tampon cuz I think you don't
smell it as much but how does she smell
it you just from the toilet if you wear
like a pad yeah oh then you take it off
and it's kind of like a walk it's like a
strong odor I hate it
what does it smell like gross like body
odor or like blood but I guess you like
like stink
it's gross woah see as men I think all
the middle listening to this are like
wow I know we're not supposed to talk
about this it's like the ladies pack
girls don't poop they don't for it and
they don't have their area stink did you
all know that period stink [ __ ] no what
did you think I never thought about odor
being involved don't know maybe I'm not
describing it right but I find it bro it
sounds like you're right I mean she says
herself she sniffs her period blood
sometimes satisfying some do you ever
find it satisfying
I always gross sometimes more gross than
other times if I smell it more but you
think it's all equally gross because she
sinks sometimes it has extra stank
I guess that's possible I never thought
like it smelled like red wine does it
have anything to do with the volume of
blood that's in it probably and does it
have anything to do with the wounds
last time you changed your tampon like
if how much body odor and sweat gets
mixed in I don't know fascinating wow
this is new so you're saying that it
uniformly always smells bad and you even
go so far as to wear tampons to avoid
smelling it altogether yes so what I
want to post to our female listeners
today is um do you ever smell your
period but so we are gonna make a
Twitter pull Dan you've got the sugar
for ladies only head on over to a street
podcast on Twitter if your lady and cast
your vote do you ever smell your period
but now these are fully anonymous votes
so you don't have to worry about being
outed or being discovered or mhmmm
anyone knowing about your disgusting
habits which we all have so don't worry
but I am truly fascinated by this period
blood smell it's a new concept it's a
paradigm shift my understanding of
periods how was their early voting I'm
very curious so my initial refresh fifty
three votes and it's about 50/50 it's 49
51 right now we're gonna be 50/50 no
yeah of course no there's been huge
swings there's been huge we've had 70
30s and yeah yeah we had a 60-40 with
the front wiping yeah no that's what I
thought it would be I think would be I
expected that cuz I if I'm a woman and I
have stinky periods I'm smelling it
because I'm already saying I smelling my
farts I bounced climbing in that that
50/50 ratio in Houlton it's holding
steady I would think that I would be
smelling my period blood you think so
yeah I would be because I scratched my
balls and smell my hand I think I think
there's just two type of people in the
world I think so probably the people
like are in denial like me yeah you're
in I I do think that
true you look yeah because it sounds I
don't want it to be true because it
sounds like you do smell your period
you're aware of this man I hate it I
know but you but on some level you still
do smell and assess it and make some
analysis of it the fact is that you're
in denial and you don't embrace it as
something you know that you can get into
on a personal level right I don't know
I'm happy that I got nine months right
now period went out yeah but then it's
almost like the baby is almost like the
nine months of period throw it up and
it's just like sounds like a break and
then a burst
you got something going on just wave at
least it has a happy ending
yeah periods don't necessarily have
happy endings except that they're over
I'll be right there with you I haven't I
tell you I have so much admiration and
so much respect for nothing you have to
go through that and I'm not jealous of
that at all I'm truly appreciative date
yeah you need to do that because my god
myself no I know
I know that's another thing I'm in
denial about that has to happen yeah
well it's really just something it's
like up the baby's coming let's just do
it you just have to do it you just have
to do it but you're gonna get drugged
then you're you're gonna be smart about
it and just not the only thing because a
lot of women are like I'd want to do it
natural I got halfway through when
they're in the excruciating pain they're
like anything depending my sister is
crazy she she was like no pain killers
and she she really didn't take anything
throughout well your your sister's a
superhuman yeah she's a frickin nature
but in your case because the the reason
women don't better get is because it
could take longer right yeah thank you
are afraid that you because you're Nam
you won't push hard as much as you would
if you're not I prefer thank you from my
perspective to not feel pain and have it
take an extra five hours well well I'm
just saying that's an exaggerated
comparison but I think that you'll be
but
I agree with you uh you know you don't
want to trust me trust me a guy that
knows something about it I have a friend
who was like I don't want it and then
halfway through she decided she wanted
it but then it took longer because they
didn't have it prepared for her oh man
and the whole time she was just like
give me when you get the painkiller is
it like no pain like total numbness no
probably helped I think it helps but I
don't think because when I I had a young
I don't know I had a huge mole removed
on my back as a kid I think I must have
been uh you know 12 or 11 but it was a
really big surgery where they cut it out
and um when they gave me numbing shots
it was extreme extremely painful it was
so painful these shots I was it fries
cuz it was just a shot I think this one
is also painful but I felt nothing like
zero sensation and I was awake but I
think I think you're already in so much
pain from the country what do you call
it
contraptions oh the contraptions yeah so
I think the pain of that shot is like
driving yeah compare actions yeah so I
think I think they have amazing
medicines that I think will really
minimize the pain you experience but the
thing is like when I had the surgery on
my back so I felt no pain at all but
then when they finish they had to sew me
up and the doctor had to cut what do you
call that when you electrocuted
categorise cauterized he had to
cauterize my flesh together so he
basically he literally like burned my
flesh together and that was [ __ ] it
wasn't paid I couldn't feel the pain but
it felt so weird those being
electrocuted how'd that smell I didn't
smell flesh I just found it was just a
wild sensation dude but um yeah so
there's a couple people who responded I
do and I secretly think it smells okay
yeah there you go exactly I don't think
exactly I think there's a very
interesting and healthy discussion guys
as of this moment it's actually exactly
50/50 and then there
I'm not sure what to choose but you
can't avoid smelling it but it still
grows mm-hmm so there you go I think
there really are two types of people in
the world you know and I think now is
exactly 50 I think that's what it boils
down to you know people who are in
denial as you said and some people that
are like I'm on board with smelling your
variable Mike I bet you the same people
to smell their fear Perry Bloods also
smell their farts and they probably
catch their vagina and smell their hand
probably you know
all right well fascinating stuff here
guys this is a science experience
experience beautiful beginning
fascinating yeah I love it
what else we got here oh another fan
submission this was the best freakin
video I've seen in such a long time you
guys oh my god talk about TLC we've been
talking about TLC a lot so this comes
from Discovery oh and it's a reader yeah
yeah I know
they're like hang on guys we got to stop
make wait planet Earth
[ __ ] cancel that we're working on a
new show show called diagnosis or
diagnosed me and we're gonna do epic
reenactments of these of these diseases
now this guy run suffers from ceaseless
belching and cause he cannot stop
burping he cannot stop burping and they
reenact it and oh my god this is from
Devon Mears oh god but this is the best
thing I've seen its own
before his condition began it's kind of
scratch you hear that yeah here I think
I might know what's up hold on one sec
we're all set up here
very professional always prepared and
very live that's right folks how you
feeling you feeling pregnant I feel
really tired and I think that's part of
this yeah
stage how was Disney for you yesterday
as a pregnant lady I couldn't go on all
the fun rides like a boring mom I felt
so bad for you as I rode all the awesome
rides and I'm already lame yeah you're
not lame it's not your fault you're
amazing you have a [ __ ] you get
you're growing a human body in your
stomach that's amazing as a guest pretty
cool yeah you know laying your freakin
awesome wife recently that's love baby
and horse this is the reenactment I was
confused that was like what am I
watching
so the burping sound is insane it's
always like and what I soon learned is
that the burping sound bite they use is
a sound bite from the actual guy it is
so he's actually so what they're doing
is playing the actual girl and the guy
every time no you can tell because they
show one brief clip of actual guy
burping and so they use that one sound
bite and they use it every time in this
reenactment and it sounds it's the same
sound it's amazing
I'm sorry ma'am it started gradually and
east though like it's like you just burp
yeah it's tiny and he's always like I'm
so sorry ma'am control you know when I
was at the customer's house and then
when I was done truck I've just Belgium
Belgium Belgium so we've got the
pressure off me it seemed crazy maybe 20
30 minutes but what I don't understand
is why do you have to burp so loud just
close your mouth well you don't have to
burp loud I don't think he can control
it that's a show about it I don't think
I can control it
he's burping a lot but sure I mean you
could control how loud you burp you can
go or you can be like not always really
never heard you burp what do you know
about it
I see people burp but you burp quietly
right because you're a lady
I don't burn yeah
one of us should sleep you know all of
that line at least one of us should
sleep look at his waist anyway to the
neighborhood during series of tests his
doctor had a bowel obstruction and
suggests it's all in Ron's head stop
thinking about it so much belching
non-stop for months that's cuz that's
that's a burp I've never heard of birth
play at my life and so yeah has to be
they're using that sound by going to
dozens of doctors the one cure this yeah
they get out look at that babe vengeance
look at this reaction that seemed to
work just stopped working leaving Ron so
desperate he wants to kill himself and
then well I know I feel bad for the guy
but like they do this sound editing
where they'll take the sound by burp
like here and then they'll like dampen
it so it seems like he's far away but
they're just using the same sound buddy
Ron so desperate he wants to kill
himself
no they're making them look like all the
time just turning into it's like a
Stephen King novel but yeah he's like a
werewolf what is happening to me
dude finds out what's going on she
panics and calls 9 1 1 records they said
there's nothing we can do for you look
at this gas is a sign to mental health
counselor Lisa Gus in her questions open
up although he does this doctor when he
burped I didn't see the guy do that he
just fit every criteria for anxiety and
depression he my way turns out he needed
an antidepressant really and he was a
manifesting anxiety in an unusual way
and he's cured now fry believe it you do
know what's on discovery you can't be
wrong
they wouldn't lie to us hit me with that
soundbite Zach
that's the burb the first time I stopped
I wish I could watch the first time with
you guys because the first time I saw
this I was just crying he does this
[Music]
think he's worth being like a thousand
times a day and he's surprised every
time it happens baby D disorder combined
with clinical depression
I poke through those things where I'll
burp I guess I got out of the problems
stimulates the brain in a certain area I
love that that video can gem my dudes so
shout out Wow having a lot of fun here
dan what's the pull out let's take a
look
we've got refreshing 4951 man at this
this tree and favorite what well yes is
going down you actually the yes is
slightly down but I mean oh yeah it's 48
52 48 for yes 52 now oh so no is
slightly edging so that makes it feel
more realistic um I feel like the margin
error though like you got to say that's
it that's a split well the problem is
that you have to vote to see the results
and so a lot of dudes out there one is
that right
when I see the result it says ladies
only so I I know any dudes are voting
there's got it I wish there was a way to
view the results I agree about it's so
messed up because oh you know what you
got to add a third option that says I'm
a dude though then it doesn't affect the
fricken you know what yeah that's no new
everyone do a new one erase that one Dan
and start over with a third option I'm a
dude no vote impressed
Thank You Mila I've been trying to say
for many years that I'm a brilliant mind
because there's a couple guys here
including Ian from Smosh what did he did
well they said I'm a guy so this is
sexist oh well do you smell your period
blood here you smell Pam's period blood
I don't want to like I won't do I'm
kidding okay I don't know anymore your
excrement I mean you go cookie live I'm
so you got a cookie just straight on the
table like that we have plates um
alright the tweets the tweets back up
anybody that already voted you got to go
back you're obligate
you should leave a comment and explain
why we reposted it I don't go and [ __ ]
this is a [ __ ] stick and I don't give
a [ __ ]
the Ian's brought cookies I'm like him
every time I see Donuts or cookies or
something on the table well who the [ __ ]
brought these I get angry as I eat them
cuz I'm like I don't need this [ __ ]
and it's always eating he was trying to
feed me oh it is always the end I know
he's a feeder and I yell at him every
time I say don't bring this [ __ ] here as
I eat three of them okay we go to a
break or should we move on to the
YouTube oh great system is broke pretty
early for a break time I think YouTube
too we're at 24 minutes okay you Paul
yeah what is it is it a big difference
well I'm a dude is winning but if you
remove that we have yes 28 yes that's
true and no 24 oh this is this is so
important this is so important for
social experiments are flawed violent
fundamentally flawed in a violent well
no not all of them just gender specific
ones it seems like oh not fart on your
hand and smell it that's the big one
okay
kela don't throw up my science I think
it's the only guys in my um can I get
another cookie those are incredible okay
I got something to complain about here
everyone who likes to hear me complain
about YouTube this is just a fun little
anecdote so I got a claim oh you
actually brought me a cookie laughing I
didn't need that oh yeah so I don't know
if you could hear that Ethan's mom
delivered all of her babies naturally
but I think that was just the time back
then isn't it I feel like my mom did too
like my mom would have a lot to say
about this so I can call she can call it
gives me more time to eat cookies I'm
just trying to buy time to eat more
cookies these are same
the [ __ ] wrong - all right serese let
me focus it got this off is the worst
episode we've ever done the ball needs
to everybody sorry sorry sorry everybody
sorry apology
all right here I'm gonna complain about
YouTube okay yay Papa John mutiny okay
this is a highlight claimed by whoever
these [ __ ] are for a song sex on
fire okay here's an interesting little
fact we didn't use that song it's not
even in the clip so I filed a diss field
and there's not even an option for this
whatever you claimed isn't even in my
video mm-hmm so yeah there's not even an
option of like [ __ ] off right so anyway
I I what I don't remember what I did I
think I did like I think you just did
like it's fair uses my my use is
something I know you didn't use it I
don't know what I did how the hell would
that even get in there well I didn't
know what I did but I just basically
said in the description this song did
not appear in the video so release your
claim and here's the best part these are
these huge media companies they're just
go on rampages of claiming videos
because there's no there's no recourse
there's no accountability they get free
money and they have no reason not to
claim every single video I've been
waiting for one of these guys should
just claim every single video on YouTube
they like thought yeah no you use sex on
fire the way the law is written there's
there's no recourse or or well
technically or a false claim it's so
broad it says in good faith so I mean
you could I think that a claim like this
for something that's not even in the
video isn't any good faith but you're
you
bringing a lawsuit against the company
for something so you know it's just and
there's no damages it's like it's
pointless
what do you wouldn't you know what I'm
saying you would need to have like a
huge class-action lawsuit to show like
tons of damage over like thousands of
users would be so complicated to
actually but that we litigate that way
so expensive and complicated to litigate
that and they know it and as far as I'm
aware they've never been held recount
accountable for this yet here's the
options these are all these except for
fair use I think or well most of them
except for fair use are just like
YouTube's way of being like see you
later idiot here's what you get when you
try to dispute it I own the CD that's
YouTube being like SIA
I think if you click that they're like
you don't have a reason you don't know
what you're talking about
yeah I'm not selling the video I'm
making any money that's the skip
I gave credit in the video that's the
skip video is my original content I own
all the rights to it so that one's fine
I have a license of permission that
one's fine meets fair use that one's
fine content is public domain so those
ones are all fine actually find claims
to make so I don't remember which one I
did but add their response is what
really makes this powerful they
responded by I disputed it and they
responded by rejecting my dispute who is
they and there's this huge media
companies I don't know YouTube
no not YouTube news media company I
don't know what sp a you know there's
like seven of them so I said hey this is
your songs not even in the video that's
the first level you dispute that and
then they come back they rejected my
dispute and they said ah I don't [ __ ]
care I'm keeping it sex on fire
I thought worst thing is that they
accused us of using Kings of Leon I
didn't even know what that was some pop
song I never it's like what so I'm like
okay that's
insane the fact that they would dispute
it so now I am forced to go one step
further in the process and at this point
you basically say your songs aren't in
the video leave me alone
and they help the option to strike and
remove the video so there's something
wrong with YouTube though because three
of our last three videos have been
claimed like the frequency of claiming
videos and just erroneous and shameless
claims have Scott I mean three of our
last view any it sounds like there's
like a bunch of new companies that have
like a whole division that is just this
I think they claiming stuff I think they
have tools because you cannot go watch
videos they have some kind of automated
tools that match it in this case it's
wrong and they don't even put in the
effort to reviewing it I mean YouTube
has got to regulate these people because
they're running amok right now it has
not been this bad ever I don't think and
then just to show you guys where was the
video of all of our t monetized videos
dan the PDF I don't see the PDF I opened
a tab of it you should stop eating here
it is again for you it doesn't work Tim
all right forget about it you got to put
on my desktop next time so that's about
it I'll show this pic when we get back
this is the best episode of everything
this is the one that will be remembered
for so we will be back with that picture
that you're promised we've got a lot to
talk about celebrity ASMR a bunch of
amazing videos Elon Musk is a weeb and a
call from GB ASMR who is got some
channels that we've talked about
he's got choice words for me she's got a
beef with what I've said about a smart
and we're gonna squash that beef here
today or ramp it up you know bro so stay
tuned y'all there's so much more h lee
podcast after these messages thank you
to audible for supporting the h3 podcast
what would it look like if we all
listened more listening to audiobooks
motivates us inspires us and brings us
closer together
for our audience audible is offering a
free audiobook with a 30-day free trial
if you want to listen to it audible has
got it just go to audible.com slash h3
podcast or text h3 podcast to 500 500
and browse their unmatched selection of
audio content start your 30-day trial
download an audiobook for free and start
listening it is that easy my dudes there
is no better place to listen than
audible because now audible members get
even more exclusive audio fitness
programs audiobooks audible originals
and more and now with audible originals
you can experience even more custom
content made exclusively for audible
members I'm gonna recommend a book to
y'all that I absolutely love it's called
the subtle art of not giving a bleep
which is the F word but it's bleeped out
this is a this is an unorthodox
motivational book because there's been a
whole kind of slew of like self-help
gurus saying that positive thinking is
the answer to improving our life and
this guy says no positive thinking is
not only not the answer it's the problem
what we need is to accept that we are
all damaged life isn't fair and what we
need more is to just stop giving a Frick
it's hilarious it's Rob it's powerful I
highly recommend the subtle art of not
giving up bleep and it's very well
narrated and it is available on audible
every month as an honourable member you
got one credit good for any audiobook
you choose to automatically you can't
get anywhere else
Hubble members also get access to audio
fitness health workout create exclusive
or audible plus your books or yours to
keep with audible you can go back and
read listen anytime even if he can't see
your membership then
like a book exchange it no questions
asked so get started today with a 30-day
trial and your first audio book is free
go to audible.com slash a free podcast
or text a true podcast to 500 500 that's
a UD IB le dot-com slash a stream
podcast or Tex Avery podcast to 500 500
me undies you all heard me obsess over
the amazing colors and prints but did
you know they've got the most
comfortable lounge pounce and tease
finally my dudes just in time for winter
this is this is like a one-piece this is
like a man skirt this is like you know
how girls wear skirts from top to bottom
guys worst girl skirts heal me just my
dick a little bit guys wear skirts from
the bottom up this is just to prove to
you how breathable and comfortable and
incredible huh me Andes is this doesn't
even hurt this isn't even a wedgie that
bothers me I could go walk around in
public like this to be perfectly happy
and comfortable and warm let me tell you
mandis love celebrating fall season and
Halloween prints check out the
jack-o'-lantern prints me undies socks
and bracelets the best part is when you
join me into you can get all this stuff
lounge pants tees undies every gay damn
thing for less than anyone else
especially remember pricing is just one
of the many perks of joining membership
my dudes they are the softest underwear
and plainly as to see I've got fun
prints that I can match with socks or
bra let's 100% in fact I never said
satisfaction is guaranteed you're gonna
love these things it's an absolute
guarantee if not send it back it's risk
free you get a refund they burn it they
incinerate it you get your money back
it's a win-win Mandy's got a great offer
for our my listeners 50% off and free
shipping on your first purchase with me
undies it's a no-brainer
look at this hey guys it's a no-brainer
I'm sick it's winter when I'm home I'm
wearing these a lounge pain
it's my dudes so for 50% off the most
comfortable undies you will ever put on
go to me undies comm /h 3 that's Mandy's
comm /h 3 100 the right people can make
a huge freakin impact on your business
and that's why it's so important to find
the right people but where do you find
those people
you could try posting on job boards but
less free let's be frank with each other
who's on job boards weirdos all of them
ok instead you need to find the person's
can take your business to the next level
and where do you find those people on
linked-in that's right as the world's
largest professional network people go
to LinkedIn every freaking day to grow
professionally and discover job
opportunities 70% of the US workforce is
already there what that's insane
LinkedIn job matches people do your role
based on more of who they really are the
skills interests and even how open they
are to new opportunities this way your
job gets seen by more of the right
people most LinkedIn members haven't
recently visited top job boards but 9
out of 10 of them are open to new
opportunities that means you were gonna
be stealing the best people from the
best jobs because yours is even better
so you can only reach them on LinkedIn
and that's why a new hires made every 10
seconds using LinkedIn now now new hires
every 10 seconds and business rate
businesses rate LinkedIn 40% higher than
job boards at delivering quality
candidates guys if you're looking for
the right employee head and hurry on to
linkedin.com slash kick ass and get $50
off your first job post that's
linkedin.com slash kick-ass that's one
word to get $50 off your first job post
linkedin.com slash kick-ass terms and
conditions apply welcome back everybody
to the period blood smelling experience
the missing PDF I was trying to find for
you guys I just want to show you
YouTube's been on a crazy unmonitored
just out of nowhere your old [ __ ] look
at this try to explain half of these
prank invasion a closer look these
horrible designs are unreal crappy
designs
prank invasion starts World War 3 it's
PewDiePie racist choice channels are
ruining society crazy feminists
triggered by lyft driver that's a title
so cringy crazy feminist gets triggered
that's so cringy to the different time
wasn't half featuring humongous dicks
out for Harambee we're just like a kids
I mean it's like give me a break that
video is demonetised yeah because it has
a asterisks I think all we do is a face
one no it's the most wholesome Joey
salads the deleted social experiment
prank invasion the dangers of social
media girl virtually assaulted in GTA
SIA Israel a vlog it's a vlog baby love
your body
Alison gold DJ Khaled Exe kissing pranks
the original DJ Khaled celebrates hold
you down Alison gold abcdefg and so many
more
it's just older stuff but like these are
a lot of our main big videos the people
yeah
71 I mean a lot of them are old probably
like twenty or thirty of them are but
these these are our cream of the crop
these are our money earners I mean yeah
cuz they still get views over that's a
big a lot of the old ones are unlisted
okay and but the ones I'm showing you
are our big earners and some of our most
viewed videos so and and the they don't
tell you they just like just a day ago I
saw just randomly in my email like five
new videos like of our biggest ones like
not suitable it's like okay it's weird
why yeah why who cares
so shout out to YouTube and to the
copyright system for helping to
encourage creators and to be a very
encouraging environment now since we
created this do you smell your period
blood pull and added option for I'm a
dude the results have swung quite a bit
yes because I can see a lot of
just being like no that's gross right
let me see the results but the majority
is giving us yes in this in this
scenario here how do you feel about that
EULA I'm surprised but after doing this
podcast not surprise surprise nope
alright where were we
yada-yada-yada we got the mail bombers
car we gotta chase his criminal down
let me get a some more let me do this a
small segment cuz we got GB standing by
to give us her opinion I came across
this celebrity ASMR playlist who put
this together it was like a huge
magazine oh it's a W Magazine yeah W
ever heard what the hell what did they
do actually what does any magazine do
20:18 trying to make a viral videos so
they have celebrities do ASMR but I
don't really they have a lot by the way
Cara I don't notice they're never you
guys don't know who she is dauveen gal
gadot Aubrey Plaza Kate Hudson Ashley
Graham Emily Ratajkowski cardi B and so
many more some like they're all females
by the way which kind of supports my
theory there's a bear Jake Jill yeah
well there's one guy but otherwise it's
all females which ports my theory that
Gibby is gonna try to dispute which is
fine G me that this is largely used by
men that like the commercial
companionship of females and I feel like
especially the one with cardi B when you
show it oh but first I want to show what
most of them this is actually the most
viewed one by Cara that's five million
views and I don't think they will she's
just whispering yeah
you really mean what did you say um I
don't know I'm Cara Delevingne but she's
just whispering and I don't know why she
has two mics why does she keep switching
mics it's not really a tomorrow yeah
that's a big part of it it's because
they're panned hard left and right so
like us in the back right now is the
headphones we're hearing her in one year
and that's like that's part of it yeah
but I think you're supposed to like use
it for like but she's no excellent we
have an expert on the lot of us at any
rate it's ditch it's just it's just a
celebrity whispering you know yeah a
cardi B on the other hand does give it a
fair shake I'm actually impressed she
didn't know if it was like she's
answering yeah look at this did my
Vickers straight up at full half-mast
right now yeah wonder if she smells her
period blood she probably does Party
beat probably next time you're
approaching a girl that you're
interested in you're like gosh she's
amazing she's so out of my league I
can't even talk to her just remember
most likely she smells her period blood
life too
yeah dude just remember she's here when
she sniffs her period blood I'm getting
tingles I like the hand gestures she's
got her hand out and she kind of flaunt
like scratching my back or something
virtually right dude she's so into it oh
yeah [ __ ] it stroke it no don't you
think it's kind of weird with the mics
in there oh she's doing welding she's
[ __ ] oh god
she's taking both of them at once I
decided and I was like what the [ __ ] I
am tingling in all the right places but
she is actually doing it I feel like she
is okay I want to know what would you be
think so but yeah so I think we've
properly set it up so let's get the
expert on the line GB ASMR is with us
here today GB how are you god bless you
thanks for joining us hi nice to meet
you thanks for joining us here today is
our resident ASMR expert now your
channel is quite big and it is very
popular you're very good at what you do
apparently and so thank you first of all
I have to ask you do you smell your
period blood we were just talking about
that in the room because we were
watching the beginning of the podcast
here kind of like you have a preference
to that that would have come off really
weird if you didn't know what I was
talking well we were saying that like
that's the that's the consensus is you
don't really have a choice right but the
question really well okay let's we don't
we don't need a diver you do but you
think you you smell it against your will
seems to be your answer
no wait she said no she doesn't know
who's you know it's not pleasant
I would not voluntarily okay excellent
crit I'm glad we got to the bottom of
that now what did you think about these
celebrity ASMR segments that I just
shared if you're watching those yeah
I've actually seen those for the W it's
a women's magazine yeah it's actually
really cool to see celebrities doing a
Tamar because you know just a couple
years ago it's something that no one was
talking about Warren had her had heard
of like I've been watching it for like
eight years
mmm-hmm on YouTube and so I know my
channel saw like two years old
I've been watching it forever and like I
was always embarrassed to talk about it
because when you come in on it at first
like this is kind of weird like
objectively but when you see people like
cardi B like doing ASMR it's it's less
weird so they're sort of mm-hmm
making it more normal and so what is it
that I got wrong or what did I miss
in my original segment about ASMR videos
because it to me
I think people I've previously spoken
that it does seem to be like the popular
ace of our channels are ones of cute you
know cute young girls not not young
young you know what I'm just young
ladies an attractive young ladies and it
seems you know as a guy it's a nice kind
of way to get a companionship and relax
and you have kind of a wave spending
time intimate time with a girl do you
contradict that I don't think you're
wrong I don't think that's everything
though okay I think most like most
people who have never seen it before
they jump in on it and they're like oh
this must be a sex thing mmm and while
you can absolutely find ASMR videos with
sexual overtones you can find sexual
anything you know people will always
utilize that to get views or you know to
gain popular too quickly or maybe it's
just how they like to do it but a smart
though like I keep asking people like
over and over again I'm like so why do
you watch it why do you watch it and
just like the overwhelming response it's
just people need to de-stress you know
like they need to relax and it's free
and it's accessible and more people
enjoy ASMR like like nightly like they
just want to sleep I think but I have
heard and I'm even myself like I've used
ASMR when you feel like lonely mmm and
you just want somebody talking for a
while on a video but I just think you
could do that with any YouTube video
yeah but there's this kind of the
whispering you know this there's a sense
of intimacy and like the ticking and all
this stuff you know it's it's it's you
know you know what
what is a popular misconception about
ASM more people get wrong you want to
correct that it's not just sexual you
said you said intimacy because it I
think that we can all agree that it's
intimate yes but I would say like it's
more intimate in the way that like like
when your mom like put you to bed and
she's like rubbing her back and singing
you a song you wouldn't want a stranger
do that to you but it's not sexual and
so I think like when somebody gets I
think you know it's not sexual what I
think yeah I think for a lot of guys it
might be like that but I I agree that I
agree that it's not only sexual though
but I know like within the intern it is
dead like no I don't want to embarrass
too much about it but he in it is a fan
of yours yeah he was just watching you
the other day right here
I'm honored in well let's move on then
he'll build up the courage as we could
say to talk so how do you feel about
this one would cardi B it is very sexual
yeah my ex are like dude she was phallic
I don't not he was given a double blow
that's an unfortunate microphone shape
but she was like yeah but she she
listens to ASMR a lot I'm like we've
known that before like she's not
surprised how because you can tell them
somebody's actually seen it before and
they get it yeah I think it's hard to
explain why like I know she gets it but
she does no no you can tell me good with
those love that do you know what's your
demographic between male and female on
your analytics mm-hmm I'm sixty percent
male and forty percent female
interesting pretty good spread my male
skews way more than that got like 85%
male people are watching your videos
do you ever get any creepier emails or
tweets from guys that get like there's
got to be some guys to get like overly
attached with you right probably a
fringe I'm sure about literally so
what's the craziest [ __ ] you seen there
have been a couple people where I had to
like get police involved whoa people are
unable to sort of separate the
distinction of like I'm speaking to an
audience and not to you specifically hmm
I know a lot of people have had that
issue not it's a lot of like
personalities and you know people who
talk to their audience and stuff like
that but I had this one person who sent
me like tens of thousands of messages
before I even saw it
Wow where did they stalking as if I was
responding to him oh my goodness that
wasn't freaked you out when she first
thought that's very freaky where did
what what platform were the messages
sent on facebook messenger yeah like a
friend like they were a facebook friend
well I had a page for a gba tomorrow
okay and people could just send messages
to it but I wouldn't get notified Wow
hazards of the job now finally I want to
say again in is a big fan of you he's I
mean I don't know if you're familiar
with Dean he's a big important part of
the show and he's a really cool guy we
like him a lot in would you like to say
anything to G B here since we've got her
on the phone I know you're a fan
seriously in wait he was just talking
about the good word I can't hear you we
can't hear you
and they hear you can every well yeah
yeah yeah he said keep up the great work
and and also and also he in was
wondering if you're single well we
appreciate you we appreciate you know
getting on the phone and talking with us
and yeah bring some clarity because it
is interesting it's wild it's oh it's
weird
like you acknowledge from the outside
it's strange but I have to tell you that
I do when I put it on you know you do
kind it is nice it is nice you know oh
yeah I do kind of like yeah and is there
and do you know if like there's a the
opposite kind of people who hate
whispering yes I think that likes
misophonia I think that's you know
there's two type of people in the world
some people you know like you you hear
the sounds and you get like the tingly
feeling and it's like oh this is really
nice
some people hear the sounds and they're
like I want to die exactly yeah I'm
saying well what do you know I'm you
know I'm not that I feel like I wanted
to die when I see your channel and I
think of someone whispering is not
pleasant sure I don't necessarily feet
tingles but I do feel kind of like a
lightness and a pleasant sensation you
know it's like extra relaxation yeah
it's nice it is nice q are you gonna do
some guess some more for me do you ever
do a one like for your boyfriend would
you ever do like a one person a samar
sesh he doesn't get ASMR those like
super unfortunate well I feel like
that's kind of ironic I guess and
unfortunate that your boyfriend doesn't
experience any some more I feel like
that's going expert for a girl really
could've been something there yeah that
could have been some great there but it
would be interesting to do like a one
person ASMR show or like you could
actually like it's almost like a massage
in a way like if you have like a ASMR
therapy right huh yeah ASMR spa keeps
popping up there's so many using and
some in New York it's call it a whisper
launch I think whoa about yeah yeah so
people are really exploring with it now
and
chairman Singh and doing live shows and
things like that do you think it will
ever become mainstream or is there going
to be something that's always hard to
explain to people it's compare it to a
couple years ago like it is crazy
mainstream now compared to so I think
it's really only going I mean because
every time it sort of comes up in the
media we get more people in the
community who are like oh my god wait
this is really relaxing yeah right we've
even seen like Howard Stern talked about
it all this celebrity doing it's like
yeah what if there was anything like
ASMR that was so weird but now is like
our seemed so weird but it's now fully
accepted by everyone right a lot of
people didn't get like twitch when it
came out like gaming like live straight
like why would you want to watch
somebody play video games just we can't
make that joke and we were like we have
got GB ASMR GI bi ASMR check her out she
is the best in the game
I've listened it's I get I feel it's
nice it's relaxing he's a huge huge fan
and we wish you all the very best yeah
and thank you been a blessed weekend so
thank you all right that was GB ASMR and
so we learned a lot from GB didn't we
yeah it was interesting that she
acknowledged that it is because I
thought she was refuting that it's like
it is not sexual but are not sexual but
like intimate or like a lot of guys are
like like the intimacy mm-hmm not sexual
but like intimate but she did
acknowledge that it's that and it's more
which I think I agree yeah but um she's
a professional you know yeah so there
you go there you have it
mm-hmm GB ASMR all right Ian how was
that for you
he like his hair yet I can't Wow I can't
hear him through the speaker yeah
no there you go yeah that was incredibly
embarrassing yeah and I was trying to
talk it wasn't working that didn't help
okay like you do find her attractive
right Ian I think she's very talented at
what she does
it's such a diplomat it's okay though
but she does have a boyfriend
in so we realized guys for that take it
easy
[Laughter]
she's cool yeah moving it makes me wish
that I enjoyed it I feel like I'm
missing out
have you tried though you know I just
know that I don't like cuz I actually I
gave it like a good shot for five or ten
minutes and I it was very pleasant it
was nice and then cuz like I was
watching like a cute girl and I was like
okay I'm gonna find a dude yeah and I
and there's this one I showed it like a
gnarly bearded dude and he's like insane
like he's all over the place and that
guy is like a king mm-hmm
so I wanted to be like alright it's not
about that but yeah that guy was was
just as good mm-hmm
but also you're not really supposed to
watch it you're supposed to just listen
right put it in the background yeah
let's be frank being cute helps you in
any field that's true if I was more
handsome you think that I wouldn't have
20 million subscribers if I wasn't more
handsome you think that people that I
wouldn't have more subscribers in
PewDiePie he's handsome that's why he
has 60 million all right I mean well
it's well known my quit actors be
attractive they say the first rule of
dating be attractive second rule of
dating don't be unattractive third rule
ask them if they smile in their period
yeah third real sniff the period blood
the sniff test as it's cold why wasn't
there a Seinfeld about period blood ah
you're slipping actually
the difference is about the same but 18%
yes for 10% no yeah 68% i'ma good I love
it I love that I love it
all right moving on Elon Musk is a weeb
this is an incredible story that needs
to be shared with the world he was
banned recently from Twitter because he
was shitposting so hard that Twitter was
sure he was hacked his security was
compromised and they said there's no way
these are genuine tweets we need to shut
this down there were no it's okay so
let's see what was it that got him
banned he first begins with I heart
anime 40 or 50 thousand likes I own a
chibi Wolverine now by the way how did
you feel about it cuz you're you have
any man and you're a fan of villain I
love anime so do you love him in him
even morning well he's just shitposting
I don't know do you like him less no I
don't like him less I just think I just
don't know what what's with the tweeting
I just don't really get him like like
he's so I just don't know why he's
trying to be like an edge lord all the
sudden it's like a midlife crisis maybe
it's like dude you're the coolest
[ __ ] greatest dude ever you don't
need to shitpost I don't have to try
yeah you don't need to try I mean it
doesn't make me like I think it's funny
I think I think that I'm I like him just
as much as I ever did I love you on Musk
I support him and his company's on 2%
and I always will
I just don't know what you know it's
just a little unnecessary maybe but yeah
and then he tweets his favorite anime
love your name I haven't actually seen
this one but apparently it's like a
drama I don't really like news this I
don't really like anime dramas that's I
like like action enemies because for me
it's I like the fantasy aspect I like
the magic
the power that's what I I didn't watch
drama anime I can watch drama in any
form cartoons is not real that's what
you get sick ass [ __ ] magical powers
because you can't actually do that in
real life
skip so acts that one
Elin calls himself Elon Chand Elon Musk
is a weeb and he responds ahem Elon Chan
what I mean what like where is he
picking up this terminology
what does trolls read it all day that's
what I'm saying like what form is he
spending because the problem that that
makes me concern is the people that talk
with these kinds of memes people who
like joke around like this
are not the people that I want getting
inside Elon Musk's beautiful pristine
brain right like I don't want him
spending time on 4chan or anime
subreddits that's maybe that's what it
concerns me
it's more than what it means that what
he's why does he know all this stuff
like you can what you could I like anime
but I'm not you know hard it would be
more fun for me by the way then it on
musk
we need his brain to be in good clean
pristine beautiful shape not ahem he
launched in look wherever he learned
that I don't want him there and I'm not
genesis evangelion that's amazing and
I'm not what you say I just noticed that
the meme that I don't know if he posted
or somebody else below but what it said
yeah it said million mean it's whatever
okay thank you Dan oh this I don't know
that or the origins of this one it's
just a pun off of a famous anime um
so Ilan continues hey what's going on
with two-factor for Tesla count which is
weird because it's actually like a
business related question although it's
not directed to the right place so
justifiably he says you want to buy some
Bitcoin
which i think was probably when Twitter
was like this shit's weird yeah
again Yvonne I don't know where you
what's going on
what forums you're browsing and we got
to keep your brain beautiful and
unaffected and I'm not criticizing the
people that do spend their times on that
forum I'm just saying some people we
need to protect Elon Musk is one of
those people you know I'm a cat girl
what is this [ __ ] it keeps getting
weirder every time I click here ok show
us your bow that cosplay he says
actually I'm actually cat girl here's a
selfie right now ok now your Twitter
right now what's your call suspend or
keep open exactly see where they came
from to whatever ends up spending is
suspending his account because he
assumed he was hacked and then finally
we end on send me your dankest memes he
tweeted what the [ __ ]
and then feet up I said meme review when
he said midnight I don't think that
happened Elon Musk
there you go what a world what a world
we live in you know what I'm saying my
god but I will say on the on the on a
beautiful positive note of Ellen's yeah
Tesla the most exciting progressive
risk-taking future forward company that
this world has seen in so long Tesla the
automaker of electric cars has finally
become their there they have blasted the
expectation everyone was expecting them
to lose those those those money they
were expected to lose 19 cents per share
their quarterly earnings came in it went
up two dollars 90 cents per share they
made a profit for the first time ever
smash expectations model 3 has become
the best-selling car in the United
it's in terms of revenue and the fifth
best selling car in terms of volume the
most revenue best selling car in the
United States unbelievable the model 3
these guys
I love Tesla everything you doing I'm so
happy that they're making it and they're
making money and they're turning a
profit and it's pretty amazing I mean
especially here in LA you see it
everywhere I know everywhere brand-new
model threes everywhere I have a lease
on a s and it's open a year and I'm
gonna I think I'm gonna get a Model 3
but I find it so amazing that as a
company they released the model 3 with
same features even better and for a
lower price the thing is the model 3 the
performance version of the model 3 is
way less than the Model S that I have
it's faster has a longer and longer
battery life which are the two things I
care the most about mm-hmm it's a little
smaller but I don't really give a [ __ ]
mostly and it's more modern it's more
futurist that's why it's gonna be so
huge so like the model the model 3
performance is like the craziest version
you can get is like seventy thousand
dollars I know that probably sounds like
a lot to most of you but comparable cars
that go that speed could be like ten
times that much yeah yeah like a Model 3
go zero to 60 and like like three
seconds the closest thing to that is
like crazy like Porsches and Maseratis
and [ __ ] there you're looking at two
three hundred thousand plus dollars
seventy thousand bucks and it's got like
three hundred and twenty miles per
charge but then it's just it has so much
more and this is not a commercial no
everyone knows far past everything else
and the auto drive is so useful and then
it's fully electric but the real the
real thing the real genius too is the
infrastructure they've built there's so
many superchargers now that you can
actually go on a long distance drive
which we've done many
times and charge a car fast and reliably
is that is that the case outside of
California yeah yeah you can drive your
problem do ya huh you can do a road trip
is really impressive I mean that's the
main as the main hurdle that everybody
we drove cross-country for a long time
we drove to Vegas and they're adding
more and more every you know all the
time but yeah lots of people drive
cross-country in their Tesla's now wow
it's really cool so that's cool and and
anyway I will be sending my dankest meme
studio on Moss who will congratulate him
on his excellent performance so what
else we got here I got a lot of videos
but I'm so freaking owned my throat is
so [ __ ]
I wasn't even sure how you were gonna do
this I wasn't sure either because we
first started this I was like delirious
I was saying something to Ella she's
like I don't even understand why you're
here I was like all right well let's go
alive hope you were to come with talking
today I can't that is true
it really happened my throat really
hurts though I probably shouldn't talk
that much because it's not gonna help
spending 14 hours at Disney yesterday
was not helpful but we were planning
that trip for a year so I would be god
damn hmm if I wasn't going let me see
I'll save this stuff for next week but
let me see and hopefully oh maybe we
could get Tom and Christina next week oh
yeah that we will definitely reschedule
cuz I saw some people worried I hope we
can do it next because I have so many
great videos I want to watch with them
mm-hmm I've got questions but a lot of
more videos the period blood we talked
about obviously congratulations what is
this one
wiping technique this guy said this was
funny from that by the way questions
video suggestions anything send them to
podcast at h3h3 productions I'll come
love to hear from you guys this one
comes from Andrew Bentley
he said he learned about the wiping
technique and he tried it out but
unfortunately on my third try with front
wiping it ended in such tragedy I had
revert back to back wiping well I was
trying to utilize the scoop technique my
my wrists
accidentally make contact with poo poopy
water wide and needless to say it
solidify my trust and the tried and
trued method of backward then how do you
get he says unfortunately I have to
conclude Ethan's wiping method is too
dangerous second
well what how deep are you yapping like
that when I am NOT when I say you have
to lift your balls I'm not kidding dude
you have to like lean back though no II
do you cup your balls when you wipe for
back to front and a little you don't but
you great I mean you have to like grab
your dick and balls right in one hand
you can go around well the way I do it I
lift my junk with one hand I stretch it
up and I can I don't dump into the
toilet that's for sure I mean yeah
obviously keep your head out of the
toilet bowl dude me my god I can't we
need to like get a life-size mannequin
and like have like a full-on
demonstration don't you bring this up
and you just you scoop right under like
that you got your leg up right now
though see this is what Oh in objects
he's actually he's got a different
technique you want to come show us yeah
come in here are you coming
god you're spent yeah you're being so
lamb come shows how you wipe your eyes
come on good get in here wide your legs
and then side around you go directly
under wait what how do you go you go you
go under the balls yes are you guys
spread the legs wider and go around
round he goes around the mountain like
from here
sure come show us come on I'm genuinely
curious this is the science episode you
shakin is that no way to embarrass I'm
not blaming hold on okay well at least
let me understand because now I'm
intrigued you go from like this no you
go from the front so you come like from
like this yeah I can't see
oh you open your wet legs using a wider
leg out super wide right right right
right
and you don't go under them you go
around them you figure sit like super
well you got homework - no wait hold on
do you [ __ ] with your legs that wide in
that's a wide stance see guy I don't go
that way oh oh oh I understand so you
scoop it your dick and balls - like the
left cuz I put them up against my gut
you say well what I'm trying to
understanding is you're not coming in
here and showing up all right
I'm tired playing pictionary with you
the Solidarity between the front wipers
is cracking you know you're the worst
pictionary partner I've ever had
switching to back after the conversion
Ian's mad at me today I embarrassed a
little bit but her boyfriend doesn't
even feel ASMR in so there is a chance
and I think I did Laius skied heels
shaking ahead very disappointed what
else we got so that's about it I have a
lot of other submissions but I think
I'll save it with the hopeful hopeful
that Tom and Christina will come next
week so again a somewhat light episode I
am very sick I should stop talking
immediately and get in bed now you are a
champion for all right through this day
when you walked in today look at you
it's like [ __ ] that dude it should be a
better thank you for saying that Dan the
show must go on you know the show must
go on
and I'm and I appreciate everybody who
tuned in on this blessed mm-hmm blessed
Friday and I appreciate all the boys and
back who I want to always express my
appreciation to Dan the producer in the
interns act the sound boy love them all
and they're all worked so hard to make
this show great and you know cheers to
him and I hope that in with his new I
think there's uh I think there was a
spark between him engineer I really do
so I'm looking forward to see how that
develops and blessed blessed weekend
it's Friday my dudes yeah it's a
beautiful thing hell yeah week and of
course a huge appreciation to all you
Kazee boys who come and spend your day
with us I hope I've entertained you I
hope you've laughed
I hope you've thought I did not intend
to make you cry I hope you didn't cry
but if you did I don't know why wasn't
my fault here boy tears of joy from
laughing so hard and enjoying yourself
so much all right
make sure to burp yeah right where hate
me with it so here comes here comes can
you crank it Discovery's crazy alright
guys have a blessed weekend and we shall
see you next week right here on your
favorite
Podcast is the music playing oh yeah
your favorite but the h3 podcasts the
only place where we do science and we
take polls and we're getting to the
bottom of it real time real science real
people I've said it all bye everybody
[Music]
[Music]